ich werde großmutter mora wird puma
riesa ich wollte doch nur wissen wir
alle zusammenleben so funktioniert weil
ich auch gerne mit joe herzlichen
glückwunsch
na toll
ich habe voll versorgt jung nur beruhigt
ich jetzt stoßen wir erst mal auf euch
an
ich war großvater also bisschen
zumindest
ich finde das super gepasst doch sagt
das mal lauter die findet das scheinbar
nicht so super sonst hätte mich aber
kaum belogen jetzt komm mal runter lügen
passt nicht zu lange da passiert
natürlich wie konnte ich nur so dumm
sein
das kind dies nicht von mir
ich weiß
es werden
ich kann
ich weiß
das
das zähle mich sehen
das gibt es doch gar nicht ja einen gut
aussehenden mann dazu gedanken hat
hattest du nicht einen termin konzept
schon fertig
ich habe alex gebeten um einen termin zu
verschieben weil ich unbedingt zu sich
geholt und ich habe mich sehr gefreut
dass wir unser unsere verabredung so
schnell nachholen konnten
sag mal du wusstest du eigentlich dass
sein freund herumhängen nein ich weiß
nicht wer hier ausstellt da kann ich
helfen
entschuldigt bitte mit
wie gehts hier im ersten schritt nicht
wiederkommt was wenn ich was falsches
sagen
eine rote rose
seit wann weißt du es und nrw achten
scherz ich aber das ist doch egal egal
kleine geste überhaupt wovon du sprichst
mama ich will nicht nur darüber reden ok
klinik du trägst jetzt nicht nur
verantwortung für dich und reza sondern
wo ist riesa hingegangen
du machst mir wirklich sorgen wo ist
reza
pläne ich fragte ungern aber ist ein
kind von riesa hast du sie wird als
seine mutter mal fragen
vielen dank
warum hast du es nicht leicht im
internet gepostet hast du mich betrogen
mal geht's noch eine einfache frage oder
für dich wieder ja oder nein
zuerst war von einem mann zutritt bund
hallo wie geht's an handlung schweren
ich bekanntlich an einer krisensitzung
nach dem ausblick
sie kommen zurück zu sehen uns besseres
verdient morgen gehen wir alle zusammen
feiern
es gibt so an dem leiden da kann man auf
den süßen rausch